so how would you define female through
my training
in health care there are several
different categories for how we Define
sex people bring up chromosomes people
also bring up hormone levels people
bring up all sorts of other categories
lots of people don't fit neatly into a
gender binary even people we don't
consider to be intersex it's a
complicated Spectrum it's not
complicated but you also didn't you also
didn't Define so what is what is a woman
what is a female what do these words
mean it's complicated and I know you're
not going to like that answer but that's
because there are no simple answers in
human biology
just let me finish
you guys like to bring up
High School level biology classes a lot
I get that a lot but people who go on to
more complicated biology classes we'll
talk about sex as a spectrum it's not
it's not well biological researchers
would disagree with you well they're
full of the ones that would say
that